hi there uh big dogs I'm trying to get
home I know which way that is oh great
oh no that can't be right this is Will
Ferrell I'm lost you're a stray man you
can do anything you want this beer
doesn't taste good but I like how it's
making me feel this is Jamie Foxx how
recently this couch
I can't see dirty too no well I I can
tell looks like she hasn't been washed
in years I'll see you later baby it was
nice to meet you I really should find my
way back home any places landmarks you
remember I remember the devil in the sky
look at that guy and Hell mother son of
a dumb smiles
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse
that is the craziest thing I have ever
seen
and I'm Dennis Quaid and Dennis Quaid
has seen some
starving how many of these should we eat
all of them give me a sec whoa you look
a little different you look different
too how so is it my human hands hold up
the cops oh God what do we do calm
down I got this hello officer none of us
shut the up Strays in theaters
August 18 rated R